hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cup head Sally stage
play unfortunately is all done so for
now I don't know what ooh wait a minute
oh hello you there's another pirate ship
down there that I did not see before
also I don't know I don't have any more
money to do any of that but I did not
see that buy reach it up over there hey
it's the turtle I love turtles hey I was
going you boss think your situation is a
multicolored mask don't you but what if
I told you that there was a way to see
it in shades of grey a way that only a
pacifist platformer would be able to
perceive would you be file would you
violent little mugs believe me if I told
you that I wonder wait can you beat this
game without can you beat this game
without killing anybody
is that an option wait weird I don't
know maybe it is an option I'm not gonna
try it oh god at all oh hi there oh
sorry die scary huh hey nice [ __ ]
that's so that's a nice fish you got the
hole slipped right out of your hands
they're awfully slippery thing lady
you know maybe oh there's that a
seahorse ah whoops oh that what the hell
oh oh it doesn't hurt me it just pushes
me upwards okay man lady you know maybe
we don't need to fight so much maybe you
and I maybe you and I we can get along
you know slappa I got real good slapper
skills you know if I'm saying
oh sorry I wasn't paying attention those
saw them wow that fish that fish you're
a cutie I'm not sure if I should catch a
release oh hey yeah I am a cutie hey you
know
did you know that I can go invisible
yeah I bet you didn't know that very
true very true hi turtle how you doing
oh that that doesn't seem friendly
why are you like a foghorn I don't I
don't like that fine I know you know I
shouldn't judge so much I like you the
sound of your voice baby oh sorry did I
see okay here comes the fish whoa
I forgot about that fish oh all right
then all right baby what you doing what
are you doing not the turtle again oh
well there she go
no not another one ha ha slap oh [ __ ] I
did not this fish is not happy about
whatever she's doing to it okay all
right I'll bite take it seriously now
yeah boy Oh yoohoo indeedy do
yoohoo baby oh I don't like that one oh
yes I do
slappa slappa slappa slappa all over the
place oh don't let it slip out sorry
and now you're gonna bow baby boom I'm
sorry just the way life is sometimes Oh
Oh bye apparently oh oh it's gonna be
problematic whoa wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa not that problematic not that
problematic at all right baby
Oh Oh Oh got it that's always how it
goes I goof it up all at once in one go
of things I just goof things up all over
the place come on oh geez so many
bullets so many bullets so many bullets
so many bullets bullet hell bullet hell
bullet hell all right bullet out got it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god I don't like what you've done
with your hair that's awful oh my god
that's awful
oh that's cheap that's cheap that is
cheap oh my god I'm not even halfway
through this oh all right this is gonna
be a tough one then okay how do you want
to flip that tire didn't even notice the
turtles are full of your dukes put up
your books put up your dukes slappa
slappa there we go
skadoosh key baby sorry
Oh Wolk aye again not ready for it don't
know why slappa slappa
come on oh that was so slap a territory
that goofed me harder than I goofed it
oh wow wow wow wow oh I was right there
damn it I was right there okay it's okay
well this one is gonna be tough I can
tell this one's tough long fight lots of
room for error it's a doozy slappa
slappa oh this is your mistake lady
giving me the full slappa before I even
get off to the races there oh yeah how's
a good slapper
No oh no oh god damn it oh god oh god
may I say Oh Oh No God they bite it
right on her midriff but God you know
some shout somehow she's even more
attractive than she once was I don't
know what it is but I just I can't help
it got some it's really appealing in
some way okay I do the jiggle like the
joystick jiggle maneuver you guys saw me
slapper you guys saw me slapping I
stopped with that alright whatever I'm
getting better all right Oh oww aah oww
aah oww aah oww God blast these guys to
hacking back whoa what blast slapper I
don't know how I missed that slap up oh
god it always aah that's a shitty
technique that's a shitty that's ash oh
god I forgot that's what that do clear
up slap oh really
slap oh really I'm trying my best
Wow I shouldn't that shouldn't have
happened that shouldn't happen okay you
know the bomb technique that's nice and
all bomb seems to do a lot less than I
think it does it's just for AoE I'm
guessing just for hitting a bunch of
people which again might be good for
that for
okay we're gonna start off with a bang
here we're gonna start at Walla sue she
poisons me boom baby all your buddies
are gone oh [ __ ] of course of course
right off the bat right off the bat like
a idiot oh not today not today not today
not today oh wow
today apparently I wish I wasn't so
terrible all I want for Christmas is to
not be stupid no oh no oh no don't
freeze me now no oh god I was looking at
my soup I looked at my super she just ah
lady I'm gonna show you a good time just
get bare with me here
I got skill I swear I got skill lady oh
boy here we go here we go here we go
here we go oh test of skill oh I was in
the clear I looked at my super meter
like an [ __ ] I don't know why I'm not
using my dodge like for some reason I'm
just not using my dodge like on the
mundane things I don't know if I think
like I'm a like wasting it Oh shitty
dicks
I don't understand myself when I do that
I just can't be close to her that's the
thing I I think it really is just me
being close to her I can't be close to
her no matter how much I want to
considering how attractive she is but I
just cannot be close to her especially
when she's forking up a ghost storm yep
there's C again it's like every time I I
don't understand why what's the slap
really here we go here we go here we go
bye umm baby there we go okay at least
I'm getting Phase three war I hate Phase
three
I hate phase 3 phase waah oh I didn't
know that's what that was gonna be I did
not know that's what that was gonna be
alright I can get there again I know
what I'm doing maybe I sound pretty
confident don't I ah really really
really really really really
really really really but I'm really that
doesn't really happen did it really
happen god it did didn't it okay here we
go
no no come on that takes too long to get
over okay why why why why why ah okay
here we go oh yeah I'm sorry but you
became to be capitated like a lot of the
people in this lane you're still very
attractive but god damn it I don't think
I want to go in a second day with you hi
I'll call you don't call me good golly
Miss Molly not bad not bad not bad
tough tough tough that one down took a
while I own took almost like 15 minutes
[ __ ] oh boy yeah okay but I got it I got
a calamari yeah all right Cala Maria hey
listen I'll meet up with you later I
just got some business to take care of
on the other side of town baby I don't
know if you know about it but uh I'm uh
I'm a rolling stone baby I don't stay in
one place for one long I gather too much
moss on my ass if you know what I mean
and it's always facing west so got a
roll-on buy into the railroad Rath I
don't know what this is all about but
okay I don't know if I'm gonna beat this
one in time
Oh a ghost all right well that's an
option okay well this is it peculiar
this makes it handy I can't hit that all
right oh whoa what the heck
I've wha oh hey oh I get it
oh I see oh I see I see I see this oh I
didn't know that so that's uh that's the
crux of this endeavor
all right so this seems easy enough just
got a counteract those wampie loose oh
what the
it froze its sucking vibrating uh mr.
Musashi I missed you oh okay well that
that froze and 85%
I'm 85% done with this game holy [ __ ] I
didn't even know that it's weird that
the devil owns a ghost soul or is owed
one at least which is rather peculiar
god I can barely hit this guy cuz I keep
having to hit his eyes which is a weird
weird statement to say I guess out loud
now that I'm thinking about it how are
they so sad you over there okay well
that was stupid of me
well he's gone I guess I should have the
other super equipped I'm now 100%
positive at the other the other super is
a much better much better thing for this
particular scenario good ol horizontal
blast [ __ ] well I'm dumb here we go
again I jumped right into it I didn't I
can see into the future you will be
counting worms well good that means I'm
not dead I guess even if I was dead nad
worms in me I guess I wouldn't be
counting him okay okay okay okay you
know you need to calm down with your
stupid eyeballs I don't take too kindly
to that and I'm gonna do some of this as
well somehow
oh really I'm walloping him oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] that wasn't good that wasn't what
the doctor ordered okay we're fine
though we're fine oh got the double
flapper okay what's next what's next
what's next Oh dreadful it goes boo keys
ooh spooky
Oh God okay well don't jump up
apparently Jesus oh oh this ain't good
this ain't good daddy that's not good
miss me I guess
peculiar about that well alright oh wow
that is precarious I guess oh I jumped
why did I jump why did I jump why did I
jump I'd have no idea why job that makes
no sense
now go stop me all right well let's see
how this goes oh I jumped again why did
I jump why am i jumping there why I got
him like halfway through with that one
super why did I jump
oh who knows I'm very stupid very
incredibly exceptionally stupid it's a
wonder that I've even made it this far
don't you agree come on you all right
how am I gonna screw this up is the
question of the day there we go
nice and easy just very gently allow him
to do his thing okay well there we are
Oh a little okay it's alright it's okay
I'm a happy camper as they all say easy
peasy
all right
all right where am I going what am i
doing what am i doing one of them is one
of my noona what a man what a man who
know what I'm gonna do
oh I don't like this oh I don't like
this at all oh I don't like this at all
No what are you doing no now [ __ ] oh I
see okay all right that's that's
peculiar okay so whoever is about to
blow go to the other side as fast as you
can no Yi well I'm on a dire night oh
[Music]
geez oh why all the pink the pink thing
landed on the other one it sent me over
ah [ __ ] I do so good and then I start
yapping my big flap or jacker yeah
that's how it always works
once I start open up my power then
things just fall apart mysteriously no
mrs. if I have no control over the
matter it's just all conundrum is thing
anyway well anyway here I go gonna do
one of these manoeuvres little bit
pretty good for you you're gonna like
this gonna like this you're gonna like
this you're gonna like this
who is starting with who are we starting
with what's going on here who's you who
are you nice nice nice epic yeah that's
the good stuff
oh I stood right on it right on it
oh boy whoa that's not good or it's very
good I don't know all right well he's
dead all right what else is new it seems
relatively oh hey hey buddy you don't
look so good oh oh that's that's scary
that's very scary all right I don't know
what - oh hello oh [ __ ] I didn't see
that oh no oh [ __ ] okay I know what I
gotta do you gotta hit him on the tail I
bet probably the only way to actually
damage him what a cheesy way to win this
I'm just standing here I'm just standing
here and shooting up that's all I've
done I'm not even moving this feels so
cheating it feels it's strategist rity
chick that's what I'm doing
I'm just being a strategic Big Easy
Phase II lemon squeeze me all right well
tell is a thing okay one down
well again very easy almost cheesy lemon
squeeze me and dead alright well this
has been a nice adventure I want to see
if I can stay over here that way I can
be near the tail because I think I saw
that and I'm gonna I'm definitely gonna
take advantage of that you don't seem to
be oh come on there we go oh oh oh oh
okay oh okay that hurts okay you're
you're problematic but I can take you
there we go there we go there we go okay
bone-in coming off [ __ ] okay you're not
gonna get me oh [ __ ] you might get me oh
you might get me oh that was not bad not
bad not bad not bad oh man
alright one of these days I'll try the
other weapons out but I don't need them
who needs them this is so good so anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching
apparently I'm almost done with this
game so the next episode might be the
very last one but thanks again let me
know what you think down the comments
below as always Oh we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]